for me
in my own business I asked this question
the other day I'm so curious to get your
thoughts on this for the longest time
when I got into business I was you know
a younger guy 21 I'm like okay very
coachable tell me what I got a I'm a
coachable guy what I got to do I'm a
coachable guy super coach won't want to
make money I'm second time being broke
my dad's at the 99 cent store too many
heart attacks I want to get out of this
yep so I'm like hey Patrick basic stuff
when you're doing business and you're
talking to rich people at Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter never talk religion never
talk politics never talk sex just don't
talk about those three things I said
okay guess what never talk politics
never talk religion never talk sex no
problem we're going to business so what
do you think about the political climate
today Patrick David oh what do you think
yeah you know well I think this is but
what do you think Patrick I don't know
you know quite frankly I think I'm
trying to figure it out for myself right
now but we'll see what's going to happen
like you know the whatever way you're
deflecting and you're kind of go on your
phone hey what do you think about God
what is your opinion on Islam or Muslim
well you know for me you know there's
you deflect that eventually you're
sitting there you're like
the people that I know at that level
want to talk about those three topics
now sex is maybe off camera and they're
kind of having fun with it yeah but they
want to talk about politics and religion
yeah so we for the longest time have
been silenced and now the ESG community
all this time they've told us to stay
quiet and they're saying what they're
talking politics yeah they're talking
religion and they're talking sex the way
through lgbtq what's wrong with that
what's wrong with it's normal it's
normal it's normal no it's not normal
well listen you guys shouldn't talk
about politics and sex and religion you
shouldn't be doing that and then you see
this one you know during covet One
Pastor Australia Syrian man I don't know
what his name is Vinnie what's his name
the Syrian Pastor priest from Australia
and he was fighting all the anti-covet
guidelines and he's his stuff is going
viral he's doing this and he's seen
these messages some of the people that
stood up they stood up because they
feared God okay and for you with your
life it's been interesting watching you
go through your evolution of your faith
pre-2022 former atheist couple of the
things you've said in the past God isn't
real because you can't prove it okay
kind of like that was more the Malcolm X
argument right bad things happen to good
people and good things happen to bad
people far too often for God to exist
I'm the Center of My Universe that's
pre-2020. then gradually you start
talking about Christianity and you know
in 2020 made a video announcing that you
were wrong about what you had said
previously about God right
now you start saying people are who are
atheists are angry bad energy people and
I don't want to be on that team anymore
and even if God is not real the world is
a better place if people do believe in
God I know God is real because there's
so much evil in the world that there has
to be an equal and opposite Force the
devil can't exist if God does not and if
you look at the world today it is very
obvious that the devil does not exist
and I'll go to the last one here with
Muslim
quotes from you Christians don't have a
religion anymore because they tolerate
everything and stand for nothing and by
the way I actually agree with you the
fact that they're they're tolerating way
too much Islam is the last religion on
the planet God is something to be feared
respected and to prove yourself too
which means you got to earn his right
it's a hey I want to earn your right
your respect right
how did you go if you don't mind talking
about your own Evolution because us as
men
if you knew me at 25 years old you
probably would have liked that party
with me I was a selfish guy I was a guy
you would have thought I was right and
we go through this phase of
where the selfishness kind of comes down
a little bit you still need to be
selfish because you need to be driven
but to the point where you're like
listen man I got to really do something
and then somehow somebody God enters
what's been your evolution of your faith
and where where are you at today yeah I
think Newton's I think it's Third Law
equal and opposite Force what you just
said there is absolutely true there had
to be equal and opposite Force to all
the evil in the world and that the equal
and opposite Force to all that evil has
to be God and I've talked about this at
length even with atheists and I try and
say that regardless of whether you're an
atheist or not you're thinking of God as
a man in the sky but you need to think
of God as a concept as a whole and once
you do that it's impossible to accept
that he doesn't exist right I said to
The Atheist I said let's say there was
two islands you're Shipwrecked right and
there's two islands both of them are
full of savages on wine one Island
you're in your friendship right on one
Island your friend goes and he crashes
and they they kill him and they eat him
and you go to another Island and they
want to kill you and eat you but they
don't because it's against their
religion
did God save your life
who cares who doesn't know the name of
their God but their God said don't kill
Shipwrecked survivors and now you're
alive so their God saved your life the
concept of God in and of itself saved
your life you own God just for the
concept of it the idea of it so even the
idea of opposing evil as a whole is a
belief in God so you're either an evil
person or you believe in God in some
regard
and then I became once I understood that
there had to be an equal and opposite
Force I was raised Christian I live in a
Christian Nation the Romania is actually
I think the second or third most
Christian country on Earth it's a very
Christian country here it's churches
everywhere they strongly believe and
that's where I began my journey but I
always had a very healthy respect for
Islam because I understand that to a
degree to have a religion at all you
have to have an intolerance to a degree
because without an intolerance you don't
have rules you don't have laws you don't
have any like you said you have to earn
God's respect if you're a religion which
is tolerant of everything then you don't
have to earn God's respect you can be a
bad person and do bad things God loves
me so it's fine well no it's not because
that's not the point of the religion so
then you extrapolate that out and I'll
sit in and thinking what's the primary
function of a religion
and the primary function of a religion I
don't believe is the religion exists so
I can live forever I mean that's a
that's a nice thought but I think on a
macro level the primary objective of a
religion is to restore and contain some
degree of traditional value within the
site how do you judge let me change the
way I worded that how do you judge the
success of a religion I don't think you
can judge it by the number of people who
join it because there's lots of people
who are Catholic who don't act Catholic
they don't act in any way particularly
Christian anyone can say there's
something you can walk into a strip club
and everyone says Christian doesn't mean
anything right so how do you judge the
success of a religion well I like to
think the best way to judge the
successful religion is how successful is
it at fighting evil how successful is it
at preserving the morality
of a population in X parameter in an ex
geographical area
so when you look at it from that way you
can't say that Islam isn't the most
successful religion on Earth it's the
most successful in regards to opposing
evil it's the most successful in regards
to opposing its differing viewpoints
it's the most successful in regards to
having people act within the limits and
the confines of what it finds to be
moral and good to God it's the most
adhered to it's the most feared it's the
most respected in most forms and then
also I'd like to think I would say it's
the most fear yeah it's the most fear
but what is respect without fear
do we respect Men We Don't Fear
but there's a man who could do
absolutely nothing to you on any level
at all you might be nice to him sure
because we're not bad people but would
you really respect that if you could
take his chick in front of his face set
his car on fire he wouldn't do a thing
you wouldn't respect him you might be
nice to him because they're not bullies
we wouldn't respect him respect and fear
are linked they're not always the same
thing and you can you can maybe have
fear without respect but it's very hard
to have respect without fear but also I
I heard someone say once that we see the
world as we see ourselves
if you're if you think everyone's a
thief if you're a liar you think
everyone's a liar and I I kind of agree
with that I understood that
I also like to think we see religion as
we see ourselves I like to see myself as
a person whose respect you have to earn
I like to see myself as a person who has
strong rigid boundaries I like to see
myself as the person who will stand up
and say no that's wrong I like to see
myself as a person who's not afraid of
being shamed by whatever Community for
saying I don't agree with that
particular ideal I liked seeing myself
that way so if I'm going to see myself
that way then I'm going to naturally
align with a religion that operates
within that form so when I say Islam is
the last religion on Earth I say it
because it seems to be the only one who
will stand up and say no
we don't care no that's not what the
book says no
I was raised Christian and and Muslims
as a whole we have no problems with
Christians none at all I don't want
everyone to think I'm anti-christian
like I dislike Christians we don't have
a problem with Christians we believe in
a lot of the same things we believe in
Jesus we put more respect on the name of
Jesus than most Christians do
I just don't like the idea of people
saying to a Christian and saying but
because I'm a Christian I can do
whatever I want and throw all the rules
away none of it matters because once you
have that level of Tolerance you no
longer have a religion Islam seems to be
the last religion left with parameters
you don't parameters you're not religion
at all
so the closer I found myself to God the
closer I saw I found myself this long
that's just how it ended and Andrew
speaking of fear one could argue that
Islam these days certainly in the last
20 years with the war on terror they've
also been the most vilified absolutely
right so you know everything that we've
seen happen with
extremism and everything that's going on
all over the world how are you grappling
with that you've been a Christian for
for years now Islam and you know what's
you know what that's such an interesting
question because when I was younger
especially when I was an atheist I would
I would sit and I'd sit and think
people are really doing Terror taxing
and doing all this crazy stuff because
you know they're upset over a cartoon
that's so stupid and nobody should kill
you nobody should kill Charlie nobody
should kill anybody nobody should kill
anybody I'll make that very clear but
also part of me is now saying
why would you want to insult the profit
for billions of people why would you
want to do that I'm not saying you I'm
not even I don't want to make the
argument against Free Speech I'm saying
you couldn't be allowed to this is a
sensitive subject I'm just saying what
kind of person wakes up and thinks
I want to do that I don't know I just
don't think that's a healthy mindset
like when I see these satanists and
they're especially in America and
they're doing let's keep it on
Christianity these satanists and they're
dressing up Jesus is gay and all this
stuff like that's not done in any kind
of good faith there's no good reason to
do that that's done with genuinely
malicious intention
and what kind of people want to do that
and then the answer by extension is
I thought America was a Christian
country so how can you have a Christian
country where the the prophets of the
religion are mocked to the highest
possible levels within the confines of
the country and and it's promoted
is that a Christian country
doesn't seem a Christian country to me I
don't think the same thing would happen
with Islam and Saudi Arabia I can't
imagine that happening so how can you
say we're a Christian country but
everyone's mocking Our God on the
streets
it's it's on Netflix ha ha ha
that's not Christian country to me so if
you're not a Christian country then
where's the religion where the
religion's supposed to enforce certain
boundaries you're supposed to at least
show it respect you know and it's also
kind of interesting because
in Christian countries there's more
respect for Islam than there is for
Christianity
in a Christian country name one they
still don't do it with the Islamic
Prophet why do you think that is it's
too much smoke
it's just not worth the Heat
because because people believe and I'm
not advocating for violence on any level
I'm saying that even these degenerates
who are trying to destroy people's
belief in God like we've discussed
earlier because they don't want you to
have any Baseline morality if you
believe in god there are Commandments
yes and no that Baseline morality
prevents you being an absolute slave so
they're trying to destroy it but even
those degenerates who are trying to Mock
and disgrace God understand there's a
point where it just backfires and ooh
this is smoke
and they don't want the smoke and
shouldn't God be feared I'm scared of
God
it's the only thing I fear I Fear God
they can put me in jail I know I'm
telling the truth God's on my side I
Fear God
so God should be feared so once again
does anybody fear the Christian God I
haven't seen anybody scared of him in a
long time
and it's kind of crazy because it's very
interesting
the max the like the mass migration all
these things are leftist policies but
then also Islam is the most right-wing
religion on Earth it's kind of very
interesting I grew up in England and I
grew up in Luton which is a town which
is mainly Muslims it's like just it's a
huge Islamic community and there was a
bunch of English people who were
complaining about this too much
immigration we're losing our culture and
I understood their point absolutely but
these are the same people complaining
about all the left-wing LGBT and schools
all these issues I don't think the only
allies you have against this are the
Muslims they're the only allies you have
in any of this the Christians don't
protest against any of this stuff the
Christians don't the Christian there's
very few Christians will get up off
their ass and complain in fact I saw on
Twitter yesterday one of the churches
was lit up in rainbow
I have nothing against gay people
that's actually another point I want to
make into about this thing I think most
people don't care and I think that
bothers them have you ever had a have
you ever had an argument with a girl
she's like strapping around the house
she's huffing and puffing and you just
don't give a [__] so she has to keep
upping the ante to eventually go
what's the problem because she tried the
low level stuff and you didn't care
I kind of feel like this has a remnants
of that I'm gay cool
I want to get married
I want to wave my dick in your kid's
face
it's like
I feel like they're like they tried to
annoy us and we're like we don't give a
[__] do whatever you want be a person we
don't care and now they're like okay
well we have to get to a limit where
they have to react we want attention now
we want them to care about what's the
right move on that well that's and
that's the point you know it's it's
difficult because there comes a point
where you simply have to address it and
now you have to oppose it and this is
sorry sorry to drop you but this is why
they're so careful and so clever with
what they do they package it all
together
lgbtq I would argue I don't know what Q
is firstly sorry I don't know what
you're questioning Q all right LG I
would argue that G and T are very
different things Beyond a gay man and
someone who's chopped the dick off are
very different things so they package it
all together so now because because the
spectrum of your enemy is so large you
have people who are complete fully this
way you have people who we accept and
are normal in society we have no problem
with gay people and they put it all
together you're an enemy of all these
people and they complicate the argument
and they mix it all together and now
you're a bigot and really you just want
your kids to be left alone really just
want to leave the children of course all
you want to do is leave your kids alone
and then it's like okay I'm now raising
children I have more children than most
people would believe how do I protect my
children from this incentive God
which God can protect my children
Allah Islam I'll move them to Dubai or
Saudi Arabia and none of this will
happen
can I trust a Christian Nation some of
them Romania is a Christian Nation and
to a large degree they oppose quite a
lot of this stuff but they're also Nao
and they're also EU and they also rely
on bailouts and grants and money and on
a long enough time frame even in the
seven years I've lived here I have
watched certain attitudes change because
money buys influence and power so Andrew
not to cut you off how much of you
converting from Christianity to Islam is
actually the belief in God versus
the societal pressures that are facing
because it seems like it's a little bit
of both for you to believe in God you
have to respect him
how can I believe and put the put my
life in the hands of someone I don't
respect
and I'm going to respect the god which
is feared
yeah but it's a vertical relationship
right it's not a horizontal if you base
if you base it horizontally they're
going to disappoint you if you think
about if you're going to believe let's
go believe Prophet Muhammad his teaching
and let's go believe the Bible NIV and
Jesus father you know for God so loved
the world that he gave us you know you
gave your son for me let's say that's
true and you're doing it based on faith
who would do such a thing for me what a
level of sacrifice for you to do that
who am I for you to be so worried about
me if you look at it from that angle
it's not necessarily coming from a place
of fear it's coming from a place of
Grace that's coming from a pla Grace a
place of love it's coming from a place
of absolutely you know or a different
feel because I do believe
uh the part that upsets me is the fear
aspect that they're allowing others to
mock your God to mock mock Jesus to mock
whatever religion it is you're part of
you're kind of like they're just funny
man so no it's not funny you just cross
the line like JC has that one line where
he says don't tell me why the guy
what the guy said about me tell me why
he was so comfortable saying it to you
100 you tell me why I say comfortable to
you so I think that's the part about
uh faith I understand when you're saying
to fear in the respect side so that's
the part where fear is needed I totally
agree but the part where you you were
making a point about lgbtq you're like I
don't know what Q stands for is
questioning and then you're like well
I'm gay okay cool
translucent spectrum and he said on the
if we were to say which religions the
far right it's going to be Muslim
totally get it they're on the far right
Christian today is kind of going Center
left today like they're kind of being
soft right now okay so if I'm going to
raise my kids I'm going to take my kids
to you know Dubai and I'm going to take
my kids to Saudi Arabia why because I'm
defending against some of these immoral
philosophies that they have I don't want
to go there I actually understand that
argument yeah and and I truly and I want
to make one more point I do believe
there is one God and I believe there's
many different paths to God and I'm not
a religious scholar and I'm not an
expert on Islam I'm doing my best and
I'm reading the Quran as often as I can
and it does say that Christians on the
Day of Reckoning will see how close they
were to the truth and we are we are
allies we are not enemies in any regard
Christians and Muslims and I do believe
that the idea of Christians and Muslims
shaking hands and saying let's put an
end to a law this garbage would be
fantastic I'm not anti-christian in any
regard I just found myself as I became
more and more religious seeking and
looking for
a faith witch normally I could be proud
of but a faith which was guiding in
regards to I don't know what a Christian
would answer to certain questions
nowadays what does a Christian answer to
I'm a transsexual and I'm not sure your
kids my genitals what's the Christian
well Christian's supposed to say no do
they
I know I know what my Muslim friends
would say I didn't if you're a Christian
I don't know how you're supposed to act
I don't know what you're supposed to
adult I don't get it anymore the True
Believer says the True Believer the True
Believer but how many are True Believers
and I mean I don't know I see all over
Twitter all these churches are losing
their minds I it's just it seems very
complicated Islam seems very very simple
you know what's right you know what's
wrong my neck is an application which
allows you to take a minute to connect
with influencers from all around the
world my name is Andrew Tate and I'm
available to speak directly to you on
minute so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]